moi je vous propose un autre tonnerre
c'est tout un tonnerre
d'applaudissements pour celui que je
vous avais promis l'invité surprise ce
soir un tonnerre d'applaudissements pour
mika
ça me fait un super heureux d'être ici
parce que je savais pas si tu me choisit
sera et pardon enfin vous êtes pas mika
du tout non la tamise sinon qu'est ce
que vous faites
je me retournais quand quelqu'un
chantera je suis jury dans ce box
non mais vous n'êtes pas sérieux là tant
que personne ne chante je me retrouve ma
part je veux ça peut durer un moment je
vous dire alors là je me semblait qui
veut se dévouer christophe we like
budget je jure c'est quoi ça m'as tu
m'as mis la chair de poule c'est à dire
un enjeu très juste mais c'est pas
entendu ça depuis la voix de jeanne
moreau je te jure tellement pas une
présence t à prendre je m'attendais pas
du tout à ce physique là c'est ce qu'a
dû dire ta mère à la naissance
d'ailleurs
non mais par contre je te dis je me suis
je me suis retournée c'est vraiment pour
te dire du fond du coeur a le plus
sincèrement possible
ferme ta gueule excusez-moi cyril non
c'est pas ça mais moi si je suis ni cas
vous attirez lanoux la jolie fille vous
n'êtes pas mon cas façon si je suis
michael avon n'est pas je suis mis à me
cacher je m'énerve je suis mis capoeira
me karaté je vous le jure je voulais
vous dire moi que je trouve que touche
pas à mon poste l'émission qui est un
petit peu pompé the voice wallace tout
ce que je voulais vous dire parce que je
trouve que votre équipement on voit vous
l'avait sélectionné l'aveuglent ça
même temps attelly la télé voilà c'est
comme dans la vie comme dans ce vol est
dans la vie des fois bon ben on
sélectionnait aveugle je dirais pas vrai
jean-michel star il ya des matins comme
dans the voice on se dira j'en ai fait
pas me retourner quoi je m'attendais pas
du tout à cette visite la cua fait pas
bon par contre
voilà je vous le dis maintenant pour
montrer que je suis à mika que je suis à
jury dans the boys je vous donnais une
petite info un petit scoop leuthard a
les yeux au départ dans le jury devait y
avoir une aura malagré non bah ouais je
vous dis alors on l'a pas fait parce
qu'il fallait changer le générique ça
devenait à la place de this is the voice
cp this is d'oeil au club voilà je viens
vous croyez moi j'ai dit je me tais je
suis gamin mais parce que je suis
michael une aide pas mix unique avait
fait remettre 91 y portent pas se
costumant on sait pas c'est pas mika ça
c'est mickey ça à lui qu'est ce qui va
te mettre à quai les oreilles tu vas
voir
ok moi entourent net
alors ok voulaient pas croire que
chimique a pas de problème alors je vais
montrer je suis mes cages vous créez des
tubes comme ça ab pour points à ses neuf
buts pour points ouais cette
appréciation d'expression de ton époque
nous donner un mot et je vous composants
hits comme ça allait a dit cela ça ok
bah la maison atlantique donc atlantique
les lardons lardons ces petits plus dur
c'est le plus dur c'est plutôt ça saigne
les oreilles là sur les hanches les
genoux des hanches et des ribambelles un
jeune sur le cul un autre choc est ce qu
est choquant
je suis alors dit n'être pas me bats je
suis un bon jeu si ça va je cynique un
an vous n'êtes pas me chercher
non n'est ce pas me suis pas mis k o
avait démasqué de cette crise
si michael jackson